the riverdale cast trying to explain  riverdale for 45 seconds does anything  shock you anymore  nothing shocks me i give it another  season i couldn't even explain the  craziness that's happening and i've read  the script and i'm shooting it we're not  related by blood so that should be fine  yeah if anything's possible in riverdale  i'd like to see for archie some clothes  on do we have to be naked yes actually  um  i think is betty's still a victim no how  do you know that she probably is only  when roberto wants you oh didn't you  hear her oh her brother got murdered and  then her  dad killed him and then he committed  suicide potentially so  i think that's going to inevitably put  stress on the relationship between betty  and jughead they might turn away from  each other only to come back together  way stronger i don't know what's gonna  happen i don't write the show don't yell  at me